i haven't talked about ayahuasca in an
hour so i need to bring it up
[Music]
hey guys say
you guys
hey where are you guys matching bianca
request i was wearing one of my famous
tank tops
and
um
and uh and bianca was like i was gonna
change and bianca was like no it's fun
so it's fun and uh it's v i'm exercising
my vanity
well cause you listen we need uh a neil
every once in a while yes with the vegan
comments and the sickly and like all
right come
push up what do you want to do yeah no
it's it's like
quarterly we need a
reminder so what the amigos call
straightening the audience needed a
little straightening
and i
i love
that the amigos terms i'm also happy the
amigos have made another
album that's doing well yes and uh
because they seem like decent gentlemen
i think although no one of them hit
so wheatie so
they fought over there oh no the
elevator
nuclear coats the football oh no you're
right i forgot about that um yeah so
whatever but uh you know
pray pray for the rappers um anyhow uh
um
[Music]
you think you will i get lost sometimes
and then will guides me yeah and there
is a new drop about it and that
is
that a boy will
all right well that actually matches
yeah that's good it's it's listless
and um
and etc boy will
um so
bianca no you go first no no please
uh what did i do this week what's your
week i have uh i have i'm doing the show
in new york soon oh tickets on sale
um
soon and um
but i've been
working on that and it's a big pain in
the uh whatever it's going to be great
but it's just a at least it's a penis
right about you yeah
um yeah
instead of stupid dave
uh it's you know it's a it's a pain in
the butt about me
um
it'll be great but it's just a lot of
phone and
conference hey we talked to this person
and i got to get an estimate
so it's a lot of busy work i feel like
you're rich enough to hire someone to do
that um
yeah but it's still you still got to get
an estimate
and
you know
um
the thing you can't forget
cheek
what's up chip i'm sure
i'm pretty cheap
uh neil how cheap are you well i get
pots and pans at ross dress for less
so they're
[Music]
the pots and pans they're better
interesting but it's the same price
range same thing yeah right
so it's just and and as i've explained
i just the thing that anyone with money
will probably tell you is they don't
want to get ripped off
yeah meaning no one wants to get
tricked
yeah so that's why
i won't spend 700
i just won't there's certain [ __ ] where
it's like you're [ __ ] tricking me and
[ __ ] you
there's certain times i'll get like a
hotel room for a night
trick me
go ahead and trick me so what i'll tell
you story i'll tell you d i have a
dave's story
uh
a group of us were at nobu and for some
reason they were all like you
you order all the food like me i don't
please don't do that to me that's like
way too much pressure i don't know what
i'm doing
i was like fine
and then um then i was like taking drink
order i'm like somehow i'm waitressing
okay cool you looked down you're an
apron what the [ __ ] i thought i was
partying and so and i think dave wanted
a some sort of whiskey right and i
sounded like him yep right so i asked
the lady for it and she was like okay
let me go check
goes back comes back like we're out of
that one but we have the
like the 30 age like the 30-year one
that one's
125 a shot
okay
i asked dave dave was like
[Music]
and then
i don't know it just she kept pushing
her luck
of like
wait or oh you know what okay and we
were like okay we'll take that one came
back
we're out of that funny story about that
one
all the way till she did it she did it
one two more times and the last one was
a 1200
shot of whiskey
and then
then dave was like [ __ ] it give me the
first one which was like just a 30 shot
i'm like you [ __ ] yourself because you
wanted to screw him over because you
were like
[ __ ] it just have it yeah and like
i feel like rich people
if they at a certain point even if you
make
and the other thing there's also no i'm
saying they would they they eagle at you
they're like oh yeah
it's what dave calls the uh real
celebrity treatment
where it's like you're just a mark for
people
and it's like that's the real celebrity
resentment and that is the real
celebrity training which is his way of
looking at things but
uh yeah i just it just
then there's a whole thing where if
you're rich and they treat you shitty
give them a nice tip like just so we're
clear
like i used to do that when i first got
some money it's the [ __ ] you it's the
[ __ ] you tip like there you go
buddy there you go champ
um so have you ever given a bad tip you
think
like you were terrible you're gonna get
a bad tip i don't care what that looks
like i feel like bad and like ten
percent like
it's bad but they were beyond the pale
okay beyond the pale you don't feel like
because i feel a little bit like
celebrities and black people have the
same problem
which is
you know i'm like
you know which is it's a it's a dice
game of how you're gonna tip the
stereotype
right yes you have to overcome do you
over compensate so yeah everyone says oh
oh you know but i they've overturned
stereotypes right which is impossible
it's impossible it doesn't help
but
do you feel the like just give them a
good tip so i don't
uh
there's like the
i'm not that famous so it's not it it
depends but it's more like famous right
so there's more
i don't it just trying not to be
walking
towing the
uh skirting the line between
being an [ __ ] and proving a point the
neil brennan story walk it like you
talking while i was straining him
um it's great scraping um
and and then of course i did plant
medicine for the final
time before my trip over the weekend and
it was uh
stupid
um
score
well it's all it's already like an a
plus right but of the eight within the a
plus i'd put it squarely in the middle
plus of a plus
i i know it's not an a plus plus it's an
a plus okay so but great
mother mother ayah thank you hi
spirits angels should i not believe in
uh mediumship mentors i believe in it
all bianca i'm a i'm a goofy
i'm a i'm a leafy [ __ ] lady
yeah
did a healing yeah you don't have any
idea what's happening with me i i'm
barely a comedian anymore
barely um yeah it's wild so but
incredible
um yay yeah fantastic thank you thank
you plants thanks no one cares
[Laughter]
great
will's getting so good he's really he's
really getting that boy will um
he's really come from such a bad place
to really get to a place that's
acceptable the will story um
so what did i do
i had i had a very intense lymphatic
massage
um a korean guy
and he's he's hilarious he's like
you know obviously i'm not going to do
the accent but every morning i would
never
uh
every morning
i'm imagining in my head right now go
ahead
um
i've got shane gillis in my head
the guy who got like who got rejected
uh at one point he puts a vibrating
thing near my groin which is a little
weird uh because he's like that's where
your lymph nodes are
i'm like
is that sex
but yeah no so he said every morning
you wake up
punch each armpit for a minute wake up
the lymph nodes get your juices flowing
literally my i'm like thinner and more
healthy from one
lymphatic massage from punching your
armpits no no that's my upkeep got it
from him doing the
doing all the things
you're not imagining no because i have a
body measure
wow okay um
i also
give me one
you're not healthy also i want it
uh no so it's i he's like tell me what
to drink or not like it's very lovely
but i i like chinese medicine all that
[ __ ] i have a chinese medicine doctor so
celery juice is having a moment it is
but it's like not as
as you think it's all good i know well
that's the thing is there's so
many just dealing with the
the the world i'm dealing with now i'm
like at what point do you just go nah
that's [ __ ]
like no i'm not doing i don't need
selenite right wands crystal wands where
you go [ __ ] this
no
no i don't need it that's where i get
that's where somehow i get narda comes
back yeah i get cheap where i'm like nah
i'm not getting selenite wands thanks
um
so
you know it's fine
it's like
that's it's like house spirit project
how spirits
uh yeah at a certain point you just go
i'm not i'm not doing that
thank you now i just want to remind you
when i said about my friend who has a
mat of crushed amethyst
that made me unsick and you're like
wow
wow
yeah
hey you've gone too far yeah you were
not into it right but i mean now you're
okay
it's called being born again
and it's something that happened to me
now i don't know about this cellulite
crystal but that it crushed amethyst
matte from japan
if you really want to pop it off
who knows who knows what who knows magic
wand
but i'm also leaving for months so who
knows you guys so neil's this is back
just smoking marlborough's in new york
i'm gonna miss you i know i'm gonna miss
you
we're going to be video we're going to
be a video
yes i do a gratitude list every night
and sometimes you're on it really yeah
can i see
oh yeah
that's nice
granite list not
the you know i promise i get used to
everything so quickly where i don't eat
i just do a gratitude list and i'm not
like i'm like phoning it in but just
like all right and then i do that you're
not like that i'm not
really they say like doing a gratitude
journal makes you
uh feel better overall
does it
i don't i get used to [ __ ] so quickly
that i don't it may not
it may not [ __ ] like that may not work
for me
okay
what if you did a journal of people
you're you're you have no gratitude for
it i feel like that wouldn't get it no
that well yeah but i'm trying not to be
that guy oh
but i think you could do a fresh one
every night forget it and really get
that really get there but that's what
we're trying to get away from okay i
understand it's called growth okay it's
a growth mindset and i
have it
and i correct it nothing
bums me out more than when people say
you know i'm looking for somebody with a
growth mindset like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about terrible on dating
sites oh yes a growth mind's like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about
what do you talk what tell me what
you're talking about because it is
nonsense right
um anyhow are you excited for new york
or does it feel like you know when
you're really pumped for something you
have to do big or you're just like [ __ ]
that's gonna be a lot of work
well
the bigger issue is i haven't really
done the show
whereas three mics i'd done
you did it i did it five times in
montreal and then i did it
three or four times here i did it like
nine or ten times before i did in new
york this i'm doing once
what oh
like tiny salon like people's living
room version i don't know what the [ __ ]
to do yeah because i need to practice it
and need to know what works before
people come
i'd like to tickets most likely going to
be in august no yeah
but say on sale the on sale date it's
going to be before that so
i'm
and
i don't want to i don't i don't
i don't want to hang out in comedy clubs
like i used to why so
uh i have my reasons
have they lost their luster
i just realized i don't have to do
stand-up as much as i was doing it yeah
and so i'm not like i'm gonna do nine
spots a night all right
unless i have something to work out i'm
just
i'm just getting used to it it's not
helpful and there's no way to work this
out in comedy clubs
not really the comedy parts are
what they are like how many parts work
it's just the
connective tissue
um the ligaments the torn yeah the the
fascia
so
so you've seen these cobin numbers in
america
no i haven't haven't checked in a while
they don't they aren't making my
gratitude
they are they should why because
yesterday was 90. the highest was 90.
wait now in the new york times 90 people
died yesterday from that's like flu in
all of america yes
sundays are slow days
because they statistically
they don't care they don't come yet you
got to be real special to get counted
you really have to really die on sunday
you have to like in combust
for people to even notice but but even
for a country of
hundreds of millions of people
like
uh in the a few hundred people is so low
to die from something
90.
and it makes you wonder
w
so it seems like the vaccine works
i could be dead wrong right but it seems
like it works
i i'm real bad with numbers in charge
but it seemed i'm seeing the numbers
crest and then they go down
precipitously and then continue down on
a real nice slope from around uh mid
april
to now they we were averaging uh
uh 80 000 new cases a day and now we're
averaging around
uh 10 000. imagine you're getting
covered now like so
well that's the thing where people name
it it's like where you're uh actually
rude people are dying well it's it's
like final destination or something
right it's like people like ah we i'm
good i think i think we're good
[ __ ] here comes that that saw blade
that band saw comes and [ __ ]
decapitates you uh but
if you get the vaccine you're not gonna
die andy you if you're in california you
get a 50 gift card
everybody dude not us which is [ __ ]
if only if
you know
after may 17th
i was gonna buy some pots and pans
and uh or after may june
[Music]
ian have raw stress for less
carrying back no uh i don't have one now
i think i do actually that's pretty good
well it doesn't say ross it says nautica
but oh i i had to get
um
i had to get this is interesting i had
to go to ross i went to ross to get like
a you know
piece of luggage
and uh talking to biking because you
should have told me i have so much
luggage and i was like
why would i go hey
can i get some luggage do you have any
luggage
and here's what i learned
every season
the every nba player gets five new
pieces of luggage from
whatever the company is
and they have their number on it
and all that so that when they load it
they get once they get to the plane
they are met by whomever
works for the team everybody's got four
bags
blake's number
whatever seven now seven has four bags
and then when they land when they get to
the hotel
they've put their [ __ ] in their room
oh that's nice yeah that's nice
but they only make like 40 million
dollars a year dude
they have their own
planes sorry that's probably a stupid
question they're not as nice as they
should be though they're like nice but
they don't they're not reclining they
don't like you can't sleep
they're not like first class like
reclining it's weird like that's wait
they're not that nice i know they're
like nice but they're not
they really have a lot of leg legroom
they do have leg room and then maybe
that's where they're losing a lot of uh
losing a lot of
salt anyhow yeah can you imagine walking
around the airport with blake's number
on your luggage i have a piece of it and
it feels pretty silly
like i'm number 34 for the clippers or
whatever the [ __ ] number he was
um and i used it once and was like
yeah i also it i checked the bag it's
big checked bags so that you know that's
not my speed although maybe this trip
because i
need to bring a bunch of were you airbnb
or you got a furnished rental uh here's
the thing about me i don't like uh
singing friends please yeah i feel like
that's the famous people i know but i
don't want to be like aziz what's the
code i just don't want to be like what's
the who's what's the super's name i
can't get in touch with like i just
don't want to let me just get a pamphlet
let me get a binder with the information
in it the wi-fi the uh that's it
i don't need where's you where do you
keep your
i'm not doing that let me i'll pay
not to have that relationship to not to
have to ask
um
gerard where he keeps his bottle opener
okay or like what's the deal with the
toilet i just we're not playing that
i'll go through a
furnished rental place sooner than i'll
go through
um
we're going through rocks uh
rock's new rock apparently amazing news
apparently i don't know why it made the
news they didn't realize it was like
um
yeah the it's i can't get into it but
it's funny
anyhow so the coven numbers are good and
i'm i mean it's we're getting to rest in
power king right numbers um in america
in america an asterisk in america only
or as or as americans call it the earth
it's literally american supremacy we
have
we reign supreme in the land although
i'm reminded of a headline when the
america landed on mar the mars rover
we were in canada shooting half baked
and the um headline in the canadian
newspaper was
earth lands on mars i was like was it
earth
it's like what did was the headline
earth invades vietnam right
give us our [ __ ] do when we did it
[ __ ] stop it earth lands on mars my
[ __ ] ass give us our poop give us uh
i spoke to
will column jerry seinfeld on the
telephone and i went and spoke in a
while it was like i would just like to
start by saying i think you're great
and uh and he was like now we're talking
or something and then i was like you
know when you talk to one of the pooh
boss
and he goes give me my poo box
yeah
give me my boo-boos um give me my give
her my poop it's so [ __ ] funny and
proving once again that jerry smith is
very give me my food give me my poo-poos
um
so uh
yeah
anyhow
moving on
what is this cueing on oh so the fbi
warned
congress
people that
the best people the best people in
congress about all things that uh
they're seeing
a trend that they're moving from digital
soldiers right to
uh
just real life violent attack like what
are they called dve domestic
violent extremist there we go
so there's a actual it's actually very
scary when you read it but it's
basically saying
that um
because a lot of cues
predictions haven't
um
actually like manifested in real life
in fact none of them
from what from what i can tell i guess
there's another big date coming in
august well here's the thing instead of
deterring them and
making people think oh
this is some [ __ ] yeah it's having
an adverse effect
and it's making people think like okay
well we got to take over it's the it's
yeah no it's the it's uh
q can't get it done so we gotta get it
not the right guy anymore yeah sort of
thing and it's
the funny thing is though the fbi made a
really clear distinction
that they are only going to
monitor
and
uh
like keep track of
q and on and people you know engaging in
q and conspiracies and online whatever
the [ __ ]
they're only going to do it when it's
linked to a federal crime if it is not
linked to a federal crime
they're not investigating them in any
way shape or form except if it's that
so if it's a local crime can local
police investigate
they just made it they said we want to
be really clear that we're not
investigating qnon as a movement like as
a movement
we're just investigating when it
has ties to an actual crime well it
i mean which is but then you think about
it but also how the [ __ ] are they gonna
what are they gonna do
it's
it's as we discussed apophenia which is
the thing that those people have where
they see symbols in everything yeah
if even if they investigate it and take
it down
then
didn't the guy quit didn't queue quit
the guy who was someone else wait and
then so so it's we couldn't get through
the door what are they gonna do shut the
internet down like the [ __ ] are they
gonna do what i don't get is that
there's whenever it's
black organizations i mean they know
they monitor you they're you're they
know where you live i think the key is q
anon doesn't want to serve breakfast in
the hood
i think the big difference is the
mistake that the black panthers made was
offering breakfast
free breakfast
and i think if q anon stays away from
breakfast they're good they're fine
they're good uh it's weird that they
made that distinction now in my head i
was like well what if they were saying
it to be like no no no you keep doing
your thinking no no no no don't change
the thing in fact we have this phone
this great phone that's that's uh
that's uh got uh protection on both
sides and [ __ ] whatever it's called
encrypted right on both ends
to end encryption
double double-sided
dildos of encryption
[Music]
it was honestly though when you read it
i didn't read the whole report but it
was
just warning them that like this is
going to manifest in actual real life in
the name of kyunan
just so we told you so
it's an information
orgy the internet is an information orgy
and the thing about orgies is
the good ones
have
the good ones have protection the wild
ones i'm betting
not a lot of protection no uh but i'm
assuming the good ones you get tested
beforehand everybody wears protection
this is a
free-for-all and
there i
don't know
maybe too late for us
yeah i just feel like domestic terror
attacks are gonna be
more i mean they're just so normal to us
now but we call them mass shootings
yeah i mean i just yeah like what i
don't know what to make of the warning i
mean fbi doesn't always just give like
warning to all of congress no one shot
i mean that guy went to pete's the pizza
party galaxy pizza
no it's called but he didn't i think
it's galaxy pizza and d so it's called a
pizzagate pizza place is called um
comet comet ping pong
so
i don't know where i got galaxy from but
wow happy to be here nothing could be
further from oh
um space pizza
uh outer space pizza um yes so
that guy didn't
no one he didn't he didn't hurt anybody
he wanted he was thinking about it he
had to investigate
the good news is
much like
remember the shoe bomber
oh yeah the had the maybe the dumbest
looking person ever and but affected
that affected everybody yeah i was still
thankful i mean how dumb could it be
meanwhile we're all still taking her
shoes off 15. well not me
i got put up preachy oh yeah i do too um
although i'm afraid it's going to expire
i don't think they're going to give us
credit for pandemic how long does
pre-check last five years i think oh did
you get the globe globally i have global
entry and you guys know but you get
double you get double pre-check
but global entry no nowhere else in the
globe does it work
i know well the problem is flying it's
good flying back
but the problem is the kiosk at la is so
good now it barely takes any time even
without pre without global entry but
it's fun thing to have clear you got
clear sweetheart
i got it all okay oh yeah don't insult
me
of course it got clear
although
no clear is good there's one of them
that's like that's like super clear or
like right and you're like all right now
you rip me off this is 1200 whiskey
go [ __ ] yourself
um
don't don't mistake my wealth for
foolishness
fool
um so
i don't know what to do about q anon i
hope that it's like the dumb michigan
wolverine
pack
dummies now they did say what you're
saying which is
when the this because of this isn't this
is a new administration just people fall
off people get disinterested
it doesn't happen yeah yeah yeah well
it's a lot of
it so it's just going to be extremists
left but there's not going to be as many
people being like cute
yeah well it when nothing happens at a
certain point you stop believing in
santa
like you know like you just will go well
he keeps not showing up so i'm thinking
i get the feeling this is fake and when
there's documentary saying like it's
fake and everyone says it's fake you'll
go like no [ __ ] you for like a while
on your own you'll be like you're like
stupid you know
i i believe it it's like people that i
know people that didn't believe in covet
got it and i'm still like hey
you know it's not that i don't i just
think it's overhyped dude you almost
died you can just say you [ __ ] up yeah
so you [ __ ] up it's really hard for
people to say they [ __ ] up yes not me
i
never
now
let's
this feels like i don't have a anybody
see this story
but i would like i just didn't do my
homework
well let's go to juneteenth because
that's that's
that's a big
do you know where that is
it sounds black it is okay it's in
inglewood
yep
i'm not a park person
it's an area
oh well in that case oh an area it's
it's a very beautiful area of l.a
anyways um
of course you saw the third search is is
lamar park dangerous
that's why people yeah absolutely white
people going being like that'd be funny
white search black search and the funny
thing is when you go there and it's just
mansions lining the streets owned by is
park the one where you know that place
there's a it's like a historic
place yeah it's where it they're like
they are they're kind of gated
they're like weirdly do you know what
i'm talking about i know exactly
there's a part of l.a it's that is like
nat king it looks like it it truly was
like
lived there it's off of uh it's like
kind of off of venice it's almost like
in your city and it's gated yeah it's
like venice and crenshaw but it's not
gated it's not gated gating but it's
gated and i know exactly
yeah
no guard at the no but it's gated but
there is a gate around the whole
establishment but there's no guardian
will keeps trying to get us to say it
it's not bottle and hill thanks don't
eat will it's north of the dogs it's
north of the town and you're not going
to find it will you're never going to
find it it's fine stop it can you play
it in reverse good job well
open up
it's funny because you go there and it's
just gigantic mansions owned by like
nice old black people very nice well put
together crack houses
yeah these crack houses are lovely um
but you know they've been celebrating
since 1949 and really
so they've got all the kinks worked out
it is
fun it is the funnest [ __ ]
it's just like it's good food everyone's
dancing white people white people okay
everyone dancing it was like uh
felt like the ending of a movie
like there was the have you ever seen
the hoop bus
the but there's like an old school bus
that rides around with the uh yeah it
has
yeah
like a basketball hoop
in the back whatever
kids running around the bus
with a hoop on at the hoop you've heard
of it
uh there's like you know oh like a
hippie white guy in a wheelchair like
doing spins
people on roller skates it was just
there's the heavy white guy in the
wheelchair wearing gloves
fingerless gloves
usually the
wheelchair a cool wheelchair guy will
pop off clubs no he didn't he wasn't
that cool okay but uh
good it was just good food and like
merchant selling
a bunch of cool [ __ ] white skulls
white heads on pikes i know how
you people do it is that what you want
it was really fun uh that actually does
sound fun
and as a white person i would say it
would be difficult
for me to not
it's as a white person it's like am i
because it's a holiday
where a white atrocity ended
yes am i there
how who uh what how am i who
who am i what am i doing there go there
so a lot of the time it's also like a
lot of black merchants and a lot of
black like small businesses
um so just go and like eat eat buy food
and if you like something buy it and
okay so it's just about supporting black
merchants it's kind of it well
that's like the s are swap meets mostly
black merchants or is it more like
everybody well that's just like the
slauson ones just happens to be in the
hood i don't know if the merchants are
black yeah they're probably that's kind
of not even the point right
asian from what i gather but no the
point of this is just like like honestly
it's just like a fun good vibe gathering
of like it was there was no like now i
got to do with you could have just like
walked up and down the streets for like
an hour and go home and been like cool
and like gotten like good food and
there's a lot of vegan there's a lot of
good vegan vegan there's some vegan ice
cream
hello i'm i couldn't over help but
overhear your conversation they were i'm
you know i'm vegan they were playing
funk music
you know i like funk you know that i was
listening to funk on the before the
beginning of the podcast
as i got ready
thank you i don't know what i've said
anymore
i'm lost i'm going to assume my own
podcast
and um okay so
maybe i maybe maybe a drag you want i
know you don't like outside no i don't
mind if i don't if i haven't eaten that
would be great okay meaning then i get
it yeah yeah go eat and then you can
like bounce whatever there's a cool like
one of them now when someone breaks in
my car
who should i
should i call tesla roadside assistance
or
do you think it's more of a autobody
place
there's a there's a cool black owned
skate shop which is rare
called neighbors they set up a ramp like
everyone's just like doing cool they're
just fun great the children there's so
many children it sounds like a black
awareness
festival nothing like what awareness
black origin is black awareness week in
in um coming to america it's just like
oh the i believe children of the future
that the randy jackson randy watson
there's but there's also just like
also good everything is there was just
good vibes
yeah it sounds like nothing was weird no
one was like
would i have gotten nods
nah not how
you would have yeah you're i ran into i
saw tony baker great
we i was like
there was a lot of people there teddy
ray was there
great um
kalani
who that singer
jesus christ did they play that song i
it was like that's like macarena yeah
uh there he is yep
beautiful
oh we were saying it so wrong jedina
jedena and who was the other person
kalani kalahani kalani kalani
kalani they just now they just
materialized right when there was a more
than
more than five thousand black people
gathering righteousness kalani and judea
and then there's a friend of yours that
i don't know maybe
i'll tell you later great
um i'm wondering who that is and i like
the intrigue
remind me okay but there was so there
was celeb sightings there was vegan food
there was random classic cars everywhere
great it was just like uh it was great
great sounds like a night and no no
[ __ ] no [ __ ] in and out
the police were dancing
great oh the police were
did anyone do a video of where the
police
they
did a dab no
everyone completely ignored the police
wonderful
just would you guys get out the [ __ ] out
of here
because it's i'm sorry not make this
about you there by the way there i saw
the funniest [ __ ] video on reddit
yesterday
where i
went to a police station and started
questioning the police like the police
question
you did the guy in the car parking lot
that told me to get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah yeah that's oh that's old is it all
good yeah he's like no get out of here
get the [ __ ] out of here [ __ ] at him god
damn it that was the most white guy
energy i was so like man what a gift to
um go up to cops and just yeah it is a
real gift harris you work for me yeah
that's
so good um
whereas my people are like there's no
way they think you work for like you
work against me sir i pay you to work
against me
it's such a great uh so funny it's on
youtube it's funny because
oh it's no longer due james freeman put
laid down the copyright
um which sounds like a slave holder's
name or something something
um
anyhow very good video very fun uh what
i don't get is why they needed to make
juneteenth in national holiday i'm not
saying bad i don't and also no one asked
for that
uh somebody must have it's not like they
thought of it joe biden wasn't like i've
got it
there's a lot of people were asking for
that as a national holiday because a lot
of the time i mean look at martin luther
king
people dresses like let's just black and
eat chicken like in arizona
are more than the king day yeah you know
how there's always like college kids
that throw
martin luther king day parties
you know that i follow racism and i
didn't know about that
yeah um i promise you it wasn't a white
person's idea what i'm wondering it what
you know i think a lot of black people
were like if you look up
how holidays went into effect martin
luther king day was uh about 50 years
ago 83 right
and there was a whole thing
where arizona
held out
yeah and and a little known fact that
white people may not know the stevie
wonder version of happy birthday is for
martin luther king did you know that
no it's for it's he wrote it for his
birthday
um
and
won't get into that but
um
martin luther king so arizona so arizona
held up but that was 50 years ago and
before that memorial day was
we don't give up we don't make holidays
that often right like it's a [ __ ]
pain in the ass national holidays yeah
yeah and there's national holidays with
like day the you have the day off
because it's still not there yet
it's still not a federal i believe it's
not a federal no no it is because there
was like because they someone put out a
list of the congress men and women that
voted against it
okay
so
uh signed to me announced that most
federal employees would observe the
holiday all right good
so i guess now it's a matter of
the nasdaq's still open it's closed on
memorial you know what i mean like
they're [ __ ] like that like dental
dentist office
there's gonna be
someone was like i better not see
juneteenth mattress yeah of course you
will um
the uh
yeah so
it's just a matter of
but by the way
it's no dumber than memorial day holiday
you know memorial day's like for dead
soldiers and memorial day was started by
black soldiers
yeah which no one talks about and they
don't like working
hello
and
then
there was a
veteran a white veteran that was going
to speak on memorial day and that was
part of his speech and he was told to
take that out of speech
the origins of cuts
look we got some a couple notes
don't love the origin um the uh
yeah so it's it was interesting how they
make holidays and stuff that
the states can hold out and it's a bit
like the weed laws i don't understand
why like you give a holiday the [ __ ]
doesn't matter because it costs money
it's economic
it just costs a billion it's like if the
economy does if people do not work that
day
stores are closed it's it it sl it's bad
for the gdp bro right bro and that's
what we're here for is gdp
um by the way this is a separate note
and it's about the environment
where we're like well we can't because
um
we can't do that because we'll put
well industries will go out of business
a lot of industries are gonna have to go
out of business
sorry they're just a lot of them are
gonna have to go out of business in
order for us to have any shot at saving
the earth it doesn't seem like we're
going to but yeah we're going to have a
shot um
you know oil is
the most popular people hate oil because
it's gross
physically it's gross
so they'll go out of business they'll
have to end that but
a lot of shit's gonna have to go out a
bit it's like yeah man it's you gotta
get all so weird manufacture [ __ ]
clothing should go out of business we
don't need any more clothes the problem
says the guy that has a clothing shirt
well and yeah i got boxes i have binders
full of shirts
you should get you got a brand new one
honestly i want to sell them at the show
i have 303 mics on db on uh vinyl
that i'm like can i just get rid of
these and i got probably a hundred
shirts they're green
shirts
uh
no the neil brennan shirt that i didn't
my friend whatever i like took him off
her website and then had extras
i know
um the guy i'm doing with thinks it's um
uh
people will get it no they won't get it
they're they're i'm selling good pri
merchandise there's like the good merch
and then they're just like yeah we also
got these no i'm not selling beer cozies
i need to get rid of this [ __ ] is more
than anything do you help me
help me
um
that was funny i forgot my point
something i think i i tricked you with
you tricked it
i neurologized with comedy uh oh you
said oh this is my point is that
a lot of the reason why
the like environment issues in
manufacturing is an issue is we talk
about it here because we're considered
quote unquote first world country but
have you been to asia
like there's no way to curb this [ __ ]
like there's no way to curb it as a
a globe at the same time because we can
do like we europe saves europe does
everything i lived in germany we have to
separate glass based on color
green brown clear like you have to bite
it and see how thick it is it's weird
it's very german you have to put things
in a yellow bag it's called the giveaway
germany gets half of its energy from
nuclear uh from uh recycling from
no from uh solar yeah the people there
don't know that i because i did a joke
about it i was like you guys got like
fifty percent of your energy from solar
and they were like what what
uh but the problem is that they do let's
say germany does a lot with
saving and environmentally like great we
don't and so what what's the point if
we're not all working at the same time
you know well it's also and then if
we're going to do stuff okay
there's also the power plant issue and
it's a real problem it's a very real
what's harder figuring that out or doing
the
documentary nothing's harder than the
documentary
um
so
uh yeah so
anyhow so juneteenth
congratulations
marching power king um now the portland
cops this is a fairly complicated story
but they break it down so
dozens of portland officers resign from
a team that responds to protests after
members so this is the this is the like
can't even
okay
so now basically a guy
who
[Music]
so you know how you qualified immunity
and you can't say anything to cops and
you can't look at them and you can't yes
they indicted or arraigned a guy or did
he get convicted indicted uh so he got
indicted and officer corey budworth
fourth degree battery
from i'm assuming the george floyd
protest or the the aftermath of the
um
and oh he shoved a photographer to the
ground and used to baton to strike her
don't love it during a protest last
august
um and he got indicted at which point
50 members of his response team
um
uh
they vacated their voluntary assignments
it happened in buffalo last year after
they pushed the guy down too oh yeah and
they nothing happened to them yeah um
it's proving once again
that cops are the biggest [ __ ] babies
in the world yeah your babies your
babies
i'm sorry to say this but for guys that
carry themselves as macho
you can't
you are you uh you got glass jaws so to
speak
um glass jaws what it's a boxing term
that you can't take upon that's cool um
it's pretty cool um
and i suppose i'm opening myself up to
violence against me but uh i think that
if you guys are strong then be strong
and also if you're just be just if you
think that it's cool so you think it's
cool that the guy pushed down a
photographer and used a baton against do
you think it's cool that they pushed
that old man down in buffalo like
yeah people were your [ __ ] standards
and morals i don't get why
we
it's like if whatever people in your
feeling it's like if you
if you
punch a
even if you look at like
dalia right at a certain point i was
like yeah
that's wrong
i defended it for a second and then i
was like yep you did you did that's not
good
so
because it wasn't proven i'd seen it if
it happened in front of me i would have
been like yes that is wrong um there
have been times where i've seen
comedians say [ __ ]
or be sexist or [ __ ] up and i've been
like yo
like i've said it on site right
so
the fact that
a comedian has more
uh
cops are the most permissive group of
people
in terms of what other
they hate
they're like very they got all kinds of
laws for other people
but for their group it's like [ __ ]
good
baby this is us baby do whatever you
push whoever you want down baby
come on right like stripes try try to
try to
try to nail something and also the thing
is no one behaves a certain way if they
aren't allowed to behave a certain way
like if you're going to be violently and
beat a [ __ ] with a baton sorry old lady
i love it
you're are you a cop yes
i love how uh
there's no
let's just say none of the all these
people are saying
a sane person doing their job is not
going to do something wild no one's
gonna do more no one's gonna
people will do the
the least amount that they can exactly
people will there's why there's minimum
wage to quote chris's old joke if they
could pay you less they would yeah hello
uh
goodwill i told you so it's like
i i don't understand why
cops as a whole wouldn't want i know we
have a few
goblins because it's the thing of the
reason guys
don't intervene that much is because we
will have to fight
and cops will have to fight each other
and they have guns and they can plan
evidence and there's just it's uh
there's a lot of ways to [ __ ] over
serpa there's a movie but serpico is
about a cop who stood up and they make
your life [ __ ] miserable yeah thing
in his face yeah but the thing is if
if going against a bad cop
makes you the priya that's is that does
that mean most cops are
is it just like most cops are bad i mean
if you can't yeah it means most cops are
bad but then most people don't want to
say right i don't know enough to know if
you can't audit a corporation
then something that they're doing
something fishy right if they're like we
don't we're not going to audit them
let's just assume everything everybody's
doing the right thing
and you know what that wasn't a big deal
the
there was a report that came out
and it was the list of
cop gangs just in la
just in especially cop gangs
oh they're ganks
but they're police officers they have
their own
tattoos
they
they exclude black cops and sometimes
sometimes they'll be all like you know
love love love this
and that's scary
that's like a good tattoo but like
that's a scary logo it's like a scary
they have um if you have a bend in your
badge that means so
what's the what's the name of this this
is the uh this one's the 28th but
there's 28
from compton california
there's probably when you when i watched
this when i read this uh report
there's been there's like 100 in la of
cop gangs where they exclude non-whites
or you can be like white passing latin
to join you have to kill someone okay
you have to kill someone to join so some
of them what if you come with
a credit a death credit already like i
killed somebody five years somewhere
else yeah yeah you have a bend in your
in your badge they have like a kink in
the badge to show that i'm part of this
gang and i've killed someone so it's
basically like a
drop bullet
absolutely they
the coins or they'll have like these
weird minted coins or their own badges
in the department
and they've been got 50 years of deputy
gangs it is when you read it the
deputies are the yeah
it's so scary and all of a sudden the
loyola university
all those are gangs uh cowboys rousey
clicks sub groups banditos buffalo
soldiers cavemen cowboys
executioners kim reeve this by the way
this is also the [ __ ] up one team
names for the now defunct xfl the vince
mcmahon
football uh
league
little red devils pirates posse
rattlesnakes regulators spartans
tasmanian devils three thousand boys two
thousand boys
vikings wayside whities
wayside whities maybe do a rewrite
one maybe don't rewrite it they don't
sound strong but i'm sure they
overcompensate for it and they just they
tear us so there's people in compton in
linwood in these places
that have been saying like cops are
terrorizing us they terrorize us for fun
they're a gang against us the fun okay
so let's say we clean that up
as a as a group of people who then
becomes cops it's it's the
it's the same hundred thousand dollar a
year
give them an education all that stuff
where
where who's gonna be cops because in
order to want to be a cop
you have to think of violence as a great
uh
you know
instrument yes to to with to uh dispense
the law but then you got then we just
like like i don't understand camden
newark right why aren't we trying
something else i mean lapd we know lapd
has a long history of being just people
are very corrupt and and uh there's no
way to do la is very very corrupt i
don't think people realize how corrupt
lgbt is it's more like chicago if only
there was a movie like say training day
they could explain it
um where a black cop was training
but people thought that was a movie
yeah it was
yeah um somebody had very funny stories
from that moment what i'm not gonna tell
them on the air but they're pretty great
uh also it's funny that it was it's now
it's on netflix and people like wow
someone wrote an article that was like
oh like a low budget no like unknown
movie in denzel like one of oh i love i
like google alerts for like once every
one of the best sci-fi you've never seen
yeah that's [ __ ] and i'm like everyone's
seen it everyone knows training day it's
pretty popular
um king kong ain't got [ __ ] we all know
that hooks
um we all know we all know the hooks
uh
juneteenth oh this is interesting that
maybe we'll make this to anybody see
this story
[Music]
this is trouble on the vip well mount
let's do anybody see this thing
anybody see this right thank you
um
so
bill maher
oh yeah
so kev said some [ __ ] in an interview
kevin hart front of the podcast kevin
hart
said some [ __ ] where he
he uh
he was in the new york times and he said
in regards to police brutality quote
you're witnessing white power and
privilege at an all-time high so then
bill maher
did a new rules a uh new rules which i
gotta say
consistently one of my favorite segments
on television
um
a lot of times we have the same premises
i just think it's [ __ ] great of
course i think it's great but he's it's
contrarian and a lot of times he's right
so mar
says this is one of the big problems
with wokeness
uh is that what you say doesn't have to
make sense or
chime with facts or even ever be
challenged lest the challenge itself be
conflated with racism
so mar says that uh
and then he says but saying white power
and privileges at an all-time high is
just ridiculous higher than a century
ago the year the tulsa race massacre
higher than the years when the kkk rode
unchecked and the kkk went unchallenged
higher than the 1960s when the supremes
and and the and willie mays still
couldn't stay in the same hotel as white
people they were working with higher
than during slavery so
mar basically says takes kevin literally
yeah and says like uh which
i think he's
allowed to i think he's like
you almost it's a bit of a bad faith
interpretation if you're a kev fan
because you know kevin doesn't
speak and kevin speaks in hyperbole like
i've never seen this in my entire life
this is the worst shirt of one of the
top 10 but worst shirts of all time like
kevin speaks tonight verbally a lot of
people speak in superlatives that's like
this is the worst it was it was the best
thing i've ever it was literally like
that's
you have to take that away just but
mars point is
uh
uh it's the
it's
i'm with obviously both of them
no i am you can't be i'm with both of
them i'll tell you why uh
because
i there is a point mars point is a good
point which is like just acknowledge
that it's better
you don't it can be a tenth of the the
problem but there is a point where
for white people i think it's like how
many how how long do you think white
people are going to
uh have patience for being called pieces
of [ __ ] all the time that like marketing
wants literally marketing
i agree
like but how but okay how long do you
think but i'm saying it as a white per
as a woke wipe all that [ __ ] there are
points where i'm like i'm not reading
that like i just can't i'm like my
bandwidth but this is the problem you
essentially like as a vegan you are
saying we're all being pieces of [ __ ] in
other ways we're all saying anytime
they're moral issues i know but anytime
we want to progress on anything we are
essentially saying what we're doing
right now
is being pieces of [ __ ] and we need to
change the moment it comes to race
anything else where it's like domestic
violence or inequality towards women or
all these other things we can stomach
but the moment it comes to rice it's
like oh wow
i can't even be white anymore it's like
it's the same
it kind of it's like kind of a similar
beast it's just a thing we need to
progress on
it's also all these things are very
damaging who cares if you're white and
i'm black and there's a inequality when
the environment can't support our life
as well you know what i mean so i'm just
saying
my issue with bill maher is that
no one alive today is ever going to be
as racist as someone from 1850 right and
no one's going to try though
no one from the 1800s is ever going to
be as racist as someone born in the
[ __ ] 50s that i think the difference
is so to me it's a it's like an obvious
like
you know it's like okay well again like
we can go back and be like it was isn't
it better though and i think the issue
is that
sure
but
what is a
worst beast a racism that's literally
just in your face no you're not equal by
which is what that thing you quote
trevor on a lot which is saying like no
no one has to lie to you until you're
equal or someone's saying like no no no
no you are equal it's the same racism
but it's like it's secret it's back
alley it's like i'm a liberal but like
ew he's mexican it's this it's changed
its form into a way you can't identify
which for me is worse which is why
people on the right it's like at least i
know where he stands
i'm not yeah i but i think do you know
what i mean i'm not i'm what i'm talking
about
uh
if if you're trying to convert people or
if you're trying to
persuade people
is the
is it's it reminds me of the way
scientists
talk about covet
where they go like we must be vigilant
did it and they they're so
uh
persistent to the point where it almost
feels like
this guys you gotta let people have a
little bit of leeway where it's like no
these variants are coming and it's just
you're going to need a booster and
you're going to and it's like yo can i
just enjoy the fact that for right now
i'm vaccinated and i don't want to wear
a mask instead of constantly harping on
this on this thing of like which is a
ironically uh
a
new rules thing mar did a few a few
weeks ago
so it's like he wants scientists
to be cool i think he wants i guess it's
dissimilar there's something he wants
scientists to be
a little bit encouraging and he wants
black people to be a little bit
encouraging toward white people in terms
of but instead of not they're all kind
of
um
i don't so i think if kevin says
it's at an all-time high
people
then
believe it's at an all-time high and
then on the on the right they go
reverse racism is at an all-time high
it's like the [ __ ] are you talking about
where people are talking hyperbole
and
um
and uh
when they just wanna like i'm not saying
white people should feel good about
racism or like i don't even think we've
made a lot of progress
um but it's
but kevin's not
talking factually
he is he's not he's like not saying
eloquently what he's saying is
why
awareness is that a whole time like the
awareness like there's people who are
having conversations who've lived their
whole 50s do you think that's what he
meant i thought he meant that it's white
supremacy's at the worst it's ever been
no no i'm sure that's what he meant but
the reality is that it's really just
awareness it's really like we've never
really talked about it like this even i
remember
i think it's more on video
i think that's well that's that would be
the my argument for what he's saying but
you know like
once things are captured on video it
does affect people like people didn't
know what was happening in the south and
then when they saw people being hosed
down with fire hoses then it was like
this is not good yeah but i remember
to
go to go against mar i remember being at
a well i'm name dropping today wow look
at me named him dave had a thing welcome
to it yeah finally stevie wonder was
there take the hint and drop a [ __ ]
name every once in a while and stevie
wonder was there and he said
i've was around in the 60s when they
were you know when
race issues were bad and he's like i've
never seen it well seen i've never
it's never been worse than it is now i
don't actually know how to get through
that whereas at least back then it felt
like okay we just need to get there
we need to get through this thing well
there would be like a tipping point or
like at a certain point where i would be
like you know what
right like stop dragging us behind cars
you know murdering us so the i think the
problem is
that one
when you start
flushing things out you know like it
does feel worse it does feel
hotter it does feel like damn am i just
an [ __ ] because i woke up and i
happen to have white skin today i
understand that it probably does feel
like that for a lot of people but
there's a few things going on one
it's just a perception it feels worse
than it actually is it's more in pop
culture than it is on in an everyday
life there's more white people in the
world there's still plenty of places in
this country that are that are just like
they were last year and also nothing is
like sustained everything does kind of
like me too at one point i felt like
guys thought we can't like you have a
joke
you can hit on a woman it's fine it's
just a little tiny bit of progress
i mean i'm like
now i'm yeah right you have
letters inside paperwork
but i just mean look
now that me too is more normalized and
we're like hey no non-consensual
maybe we don't do that
how much has changed i don't think on in
everyday life
world is that if a woman said sexism is
at an all-time high what would you say
to that
uh
i don't know like again i don't know
because that's what kevin but what i'm
saying is
if a woman said that it would be
factually incorrect it would is she
getting at a point is yes but i think it
would be
i wouldn't be surprised if mar did a did
a
new rules about it if it's like it's not
an all-time high it's great because back
in the day we could rape you yeah i get
it but it's not it's like
i get it's contrary that's part of his
thing but yeah but i think it's like
if someone said that it would not be
true it's like is a contrarian to call
somebody and say like you know that's
not true right but i think with kevin's
point and let's say with whatever this
lady's point is you know this fake lady
we can understand they mean
we're talking about it more we're
convicting more we're actually now
believing
women more than we have
so it has the
feeling it just perceived like oh all
this
sexism lying around but it's like it's
just i just don't think anything is as
extreme as we all want to make it you
know
i texted kev because this is the
question is
do we like
argumentative kevin
as a like a brand
i texted him i was like
the new chase ads
i'm not in them that [ __ ] is
sunshine he's good he's [ __ ] you cut
to a close-up of heaven heart and you're
in a better mood
and i texted him because your commercial
is the only one i don't get
tired of every and i know it's like
buddy i'm right here yeah yeah because
that's what i do yeah like i can watch
it i'd say i've seen it a million times
he's sunshine
and it's
the
that commercial is that weather
should be paid
the weather is worth a million bucks
really good it's just beautiful [ __ ]
white and then the new ones are they're
also sunny right and kevin is
so i texted him i was like dude you seem
argumentative or something
and i know how much he works and he and
and
uh
and i was like you're sunshine man
just be some and i was like am i that's
not
though that's not that
correct neil what do you mean
well
why does he i was telling you well no no
i'm not saying don't argue with people
he's arguing with like the hater i mean
he was like
karate he was twitter karateing
like and he wrote like i got time today
on one of them and like it was very like
it just seemed like you needed another
hour of sleep you know what's funny i i
have a me and my girlfriend we can we
can be some sassy gals
and she has a younger sister and when
she does it it's always like ugh just
she doesn't land like at one point i was
like girl
some like kevin's no they look good on
you kevin's
musical note isn't arguing it's like not
some people can't pull off that like
with
some people can pull off argument or
like a twitter karate and it's just
fluid and you're just like oh my god
where's the next week once next week and
sometimes it's jumbly and it's like i
just yes do you think kevin how would
you categorize it i'm not saying he
shouldn't he's not allowed to i'm not
any of that [ __ ] i'm just saying it just
is like
i'm not a big fan of like it's beneath
you or you're better than this he just
doesn't um it's not like super
like i don't know i guess what the
the topic he's trying to tackle isn't i
he wouldn't be my go-to to to handle
this you know uh but like when he said
i'm speaking on karen's that now feel
like they can say and do whatever they
want without any consequences i actually
think it's 100 the opposite yeah well
it's like stand up where it's like no we
have the best job in the world right
when it comes to saying [ __ ]
we can't say anything okay well you're
they're looking for you at the arena
that you're scheduled to do
and b
who else can say this any of this [ __ ] i
think it's just
uh
everyone feels this also kevin hart's
probably
has
a long list of
racist microaggress just stories and
experiences that none of us understand
and now
every single person that he looks at
white or whatever color kisses his
[ __ ] ass so i'm sure i don't know
maybe this is just him he's not the
civil rights guy
he is david chris the civil rights guy
like they're just that's i mean dave is
it's poetry it's like yeah like that's
like that roomie yes yes uh so send me a
roomie book one time dave did oh really
that's so funny 20 years persian
you're welcome
you know they called the thinking man's
religion like it'd be like the thinking
match
well i'm a thinking man i have to be
um
i don't know i also think it's like
[ __ ] let him tweet like oh i'm not
saying don't i'm just saying like
it's just like someone yelling and
trying it's like your friend yelling in
traffic you're like dog yeah yeah yeah
you just are in a bad you're mad about
what happened at the restaurant you're
not mad about
no traffic sucks
yeah trap yeah traffic sucks but like
traffic subs yeah we all know traffic
sucks i guess it's just
is that
i don't know it just seems like it's uh
i don't like it for him you know what
though not like he's ellen or he's like
[ __ ]
like no
his energy is sunshine
my
thing with bill is that i understand he
has this like smuggy
and he's very sm like he's very smart
and eloquent and i think he thinks about
points before he says them and i do
think he's coming from a particular i
don't think he's just being contrarian
to be controlling because don't like
white fragility but i just think
i don't know
is this the
well that's that he's
so old
he's he's too old
to know
not to
there are certain arguments that are not
worth having it's just like a they're
bad look arguments like i don't know man
like you're sticking it to the blacks
this week bill right well you'd like
to
like you know i just i and you're a
comedian and i think bill maher is like
a well-liked comedian and i think he's
really funny but
i also think
i don't know there's a comedian he's not
well like in comedy really
no
oh
like he's funny but no like comedians
wise he's like uh i think he's a little
prickly to people um
well i just me okay for example there's
a i would keep the community anonymous
and they were just saying like i watched
uh black panther
yeah and i remember thinking
why was that necessary for you to make
your opinion on that like right
well because people were celebrating or
because black people were making it a
thing there was always this kind of
white contrarian to be like
but the plot wasn't it right i don't
know it's just thanks for the
just happy birthday [ __ ]
well that's a
i had an argument one night with like
chris spencer
and dwayne martin and a bunch and like
tasha campbell somebody brought up
uptown saturday night and i go
uh guys i'm sorry not a good movie
what and i was like what's the plot of
uptown saturday night like what's the
plot
it's and then finally uh chris spencer
said the plot is a bunch of black people
made a movie which i was like okay there
we go that's really kind of it yep after
a while fine but yes
if yeah for the tournament let us have
our pumas no of course give it give it
give us your pumas
oh this is another this is a trouble in
the vip room come on now
um so chrissy
chrissy
ongoing issues
with uh
courtney stodden she and dirt knapped
and
and then another a guy named micah
costello a um fashion designer fashion
designer who won on project runway
um
started saying that chrissy was
um dming
him like
you deserve to then like you deserve it
you're a racist
and it was it didn't look good no it
wasn't like oh no chrissy moore yeah it
didn't look good and then it turns out
that they were doctored
tweets doctor dms doctor they call me dr
dams by the way
um and uh
they were dr dms
and
and you could tell because it was like a
feature that wasn't in existence
with new
instagram not the old layout no and
that's how they that's how they call it
they they didn't do the brand now how
[ __ ]
it's the guy's relying on people to just
see the headline
well here's the thing
he also this is like you brought up a
story once of
someone jumping on the bandwagon for
like yeah you were racist you have
racism in that person yeah the alexa
mechanic
yes so uh
oh no it has the purple
yes
um that's and it's the wrong it's the
wrong layout that's so um
yeah because all that happened with i
think brown instagram
but anyway good racist people deserve to
you should suffer and die
it does sound like it's i ran i was like
this is poor this doesn't sound like
chrissy
i know that's amazing i don't have
anything to say to you you will get
what's coming to you
you will again
over just watch i call upon the academy
to overturn this
so
he ends up then
everyone comes to chrissy's defense all
these black women are like you refuse to
dress me in your dresses and he has a
long
woman the n-word and and then leona
lewis was like she was supposed to she
was the star of this like celeb
i don't know a softball game something
it was a cell phone he wouldn't do a
softball uniform before
um like a charity event and when he got
there he's she was like yeah they were
whispering in a corner looking at me him
and his assistants was like sorry we
don't have anything for you yeah and
then she had to sit down in the audience
and all the press was about her and like
why aren't you walking
every single person that is a contestant
on a reality show
is crazy
you have to be a little crazy to want
that
yeah i mean within obviously there's
exceptions but they're all
a little out of them
anywhere where you have to live
with people like american idol whatever
but like
i don't
i'm not saying that this guy's a crazy
person he's a crazy person and he's
trying to
uh
to
to
make other people look bad but he's
sloppy and crazy why would he jump on
the to gain like
maybe there was just some i think he's
out of his mind
okay i think he's [ __ ]
out of he's just dr dams and he will get
no poo bus
no poo boss for you
to double quote jerry's not i felt no
pubs for you
um
it just was so when you went down i'm
like why would you insert yourself no
one was talking about you
you inserted yourself then everyone else
was like no
actually you
said you would not dress me you refused
to dress me said i don't make clothes in
your size yes i dress beyonce i don't
need to address you
gay
good good good yeah it's not good okay
you know famous people or you know
people want to be
um
stephen
why do
why does it seem like people who go on
reality shows
have a
they always have some [ __ ] bad
business
bad pr bad history like why would you
put yourself in the limelight
reality shows are get rich quick schemes
for
singing i mean some of them are you
cannot
would jennifer hudson have been signed
never kelly clarkson been signed like
there are people that are very talented
and there's built-in discrimination into
whatever they're trying to do right
right
then there are people like
the guy that fan
who won last comic standing works at sea
world now no he doesn't i'm fairly sure
he works at sea world
like i think that's
uh
images
uh i think he worked at sea world or he
used to work they're just people that
aren't gonna
they wouldn't win he wasn't the funniest
comedian
i'm not saying that's a good it's just
that no no it's a short cut
oh yeah eliza was like the last one like
that was like she won she won she won oh
that's a good one so sometimes they work
and sometimes it's just yeah yeah i feel
like it's the first few kind of work
a lot of people one that are actually
good comedians okay but that was the
first year and it was like he's probably
the most biggest bump from it
uh is he have you seen his twitter is
his instagram is wild what used to be
i don't i don't know enough about that
fan i'm not going to say he's crazy i'm
not going to no no he i'm not saying
he's crazy
so i guess he doesn't work at sea world
i remember robbie mate telling me that
um
yeah so
yeah um so uh his number is on
we're not talking about his numbers
we're not talking about his numbers
don't do this
um so
so uh so
it's the people who the dating shows the
rose shows the island shows the
those people are
a little crazy and they're by the way
they're cast because they're crazy
right it's like the only question they
should ask most the women on the
bachelor is are you bipolar and when can
you start
because that
seems to be the through line right
there's something is i just i could
never go on a reality it just feels
so strange but if i was running like a
a scheme or i have all these bad tweets
or i have all this bad [ __ ] in my past
like why would i want to be why would
anyone
it's it's
he smells delted it's he posted and
hosted it it's all of those things it's
just no one it's these are moral issues
so to stand up for people and i will
never say
humans are immoral
about my my issues about [ __ ]
or that i'm more moral than people
because i'm vegan i'm i'm i'm more moral
in that [ __ ] department right
racially i'm a little more moral than
probably most white people a little more
right but you can get me on set there's
other [ __ ] you can get me on right
so i it's hard
to really just like i condemn thee
yeah okay you will suffer yes you shall
suffer
you will get what's coming just watch
um
so
she stood on on the on a mountain and
said it
uh
so
but it's still trouble in the vip room
and it's gonna be a pain in their butt
yeah but she done or is she oh she or he
is no no so he sounds like he's done
yeah it sounds like he's been done by
i mean yeah but i don't know
we can all be done at any point now this
is the
this is interesting okay lauren hubbard
lauren okay
laurel lars sorry laurel hubbard laurel
and hubbard my favorite comedy team
um
first trans athlete to compete at the
olympics
new zealand weightlifting team 43 year
old
uh
soup women's super heavyweight
okay
having gone through male puberty before
transitioning
in 22 how old is this person 43 all
right so
she
she was a
man
went through male puberty and then
transitioned to become a woman
now she's powerlifting
so
these are this is where you get into
like
[ __ ]
i don't know
i don't know what should happen here i
don't i
i'm up two months okay
this isn't that big a problem
because why there's not scores of
men transitioning
to be like i want to win and i know just
it's and there's no joanna mance
this is a should be more
yeah like there because it's it's um
it's not it's a it's a hard life as
we've discussed on here transitioning
wanting to transition being feeling like
you're stuck in another body then
transitioning all that stuff
but the fact that there's only two
so far that i'm aware of two trans
athletes this year in the olympics
uh
is kind of like well that's not a bigger
problem there's not a lot of trans
people and even fewer of them want to be
athletes
yes so now the funny the the where
there's some joke areas is come on um
[Music]
that there aren't
if if she comes in seventh
that's funny
right well she already kicked out she
already someone else got disqualified a
tongan 21 year old tongan girl go down
uh
uh where'd it go the 21 year old tongan
weightlifter i'm not going to say her
name would have otherwise qualified
oh right so there's a hazmat
so she got knocked down she got taken
out of her place that's where you just
like ah yeah i don't can you add one i
don't [ __ ] know i see but then it
says this is what this is where it's
weird hubbard who lived as a male for 35
years did not compete in international
weightlifting until transitioning mm-hmm
so well before that she was just some
dude at the gym
and then once you can once you
transition a woman it's like you're you
can lift a lot well i don't i just i
don't i don't know i don't know if i
have an opinion because it's confusing i
remember in
pe
we had to hit like
we had
i mean this was
before
but i'm not a gen zero so this was back
when it was like this is the um
this is the
uh qualification you have to do for
women you know you had to like do it
this many push-ups
either
go ahead the mile had to be run under
this amount of 40 minutes shut up yep
and uh
you know it was all these things and it
and then the for men it was it was more
so i just but is that
i understand that's a physiological
thing is that a social construct does it
matter shouldn't it just be like
everyone should be able to do this many
yeah i don't [ __ ] know that's when
i'm like was that well no that's like
women can't do because of your body
can't do the push-up it's like men have
better muscles
men have better body strength but then
women have
technic not always but we have better
lower body strength
but the lower body ones weren't skewed
to women
you know what we got to do we got to do
squats we got to do the squats after the
show i will i'll squat you
the the one that means the 50 pound the
50 each thing i'm not lifting 50 pounds
and doing a squat crazy i did 40 of them
that's like
half my body weight almost
right so
are you got the strength or not like you
just said women are better no i can't do
obviously i can do maybe the ratio for
me i can't do 50. you just said is it a
social construct and then we said and
you said women no i said i know it's
physiologically but i mean obviously i
wear different body types right so can i
do
the same ratio do you have your measure
right here right body measure no but
i'll bring it next i'll bring it to new
york i'm going to see you mm-hmm i'm
literally going to buy you bring it
would you want no
it's a slippery slope i think you've
been slower
you have a journal no it goes it just
it's it's circle and then you just you
go by and it tells you exactly
what your circle is
it's like a caliper
[Music]
great
um
no no i can just do like okay i can dead
lift
i weigh 120 pounds
i can dead lift
i don't know
80 75 80 pounds
right that's i guess
body strength most men have better lower
body strength than most women
i'm sorry most women have i don't know
i'm not saying they do i'm saying
what is said is that men are stronger
upper body women have stronger lower
brains just because of
just another anatomy yeah and so
but does that matter is i mean like
honestly at my when i was in pe class
the chart looked like they were from the
40s so i don't [ __ ] they looked like
they were made with the typewriter yeah
but
i couldn't outrace allison felix
obviously alice felix could be right
most men
but then the person in the world i think
no no no she's
no one's going to be usain bolt like
you're not beating them um but
alison felix could
this is silly but
but
what i'm i think the interesting one
will be when a
man transitions to woman and plays in
the wnba
um that i don't want a man i mean the
real johanna man or the real
i'm trying to think of other sports that
like there's a lot tennis would be
but in the situation where there are
what do you tell the tongan girl what do
you tell
if she wins the gold medal
yeah now having said that
it's not like the spoils of winning
women's powerlifting shall be
uh revealed
i mean well people like attention i'm
sure it's like nice to be like yo i
excelled this thing yep i am now the
gender i feel like i was and i'm doing
something yes i'm also honest like good
for you
i'm i'm happy for the lady
and i'm unhappy for the tongan lady and
i feel like i just wish there was
something we can agree too complicated
does it matter if you does it matter i
don't know if you know this but that if
you went through puberty or not
he went through male people no i
understand he did i'm saying i'm sorry
i yeah she did i i'm just saying if
let's say someone did a transition like
hormonal transition or whatever before
puberty do they not develop certain
things that or is it the strength first
one you take is like a puberty blocker
and then you take
female hormones if you want to
transition from man to woman you take
female hormones you grow breasts you
all the female stuff and
um
and
that's what the british one was about
it's like
kids at what age should they be allowed
to do it and it's and then they change
their mind and just like [ __ ] okay
question you might not know
is it
trans like
hey
neil is looks exactly like neil doesn't
do any transition but like i just i
identify as a woman right now
is that kind of
is that a
like what we're talking about or do you
have to have no you have to you have to
have there's a thing about their
testosterone levels
ioc's decisions come under fire after
scientific papers were published which
said that people who have undergone male
puberty retained significant advantages
including in power and strength even
after taking medication to suppress
their testosterone levels interesting
honestly to me this is ends up they
provide their total testosterone level
is kept below 10
nanomoles per liter for at least 12
months okay great
uh good luck good luck keeping it under
the 10 nanomoles am i right fellas
fellas are you am i crazy with it i mean
i i'm riding
guy you he came in here he had to be
pushing easy 50 nanomoles
of testosterone it feels like a
scientific decision or a medical science
and it is no but like it's also turns
into a but it's more or less it becomes
yes and
and we don't have enough animals i don't
know i don't get the animals bro
um
so
uh let's uh let's do some emails well
now that people wait to talk about my
one thing
my victory secret oh yeah let's talk
about that
so
victoria secrets now
doing away with uh angels
and they're gonna do they're just gonna
highlight
women who uh
have women have bodies no no no like uh
sports players like people who've done
things like almost like a
humanitarian award type of thing oh well
they picked um
priyanka chopra so she i don't know and
she's still pretty good what i'm saying
is like she looks like a mom they're
gonna sprinkle in
regular ladies they're going to get the
ladies from dove
to come back where are they now
i just i'm wondering if that
it's a little if you've
spent the better half of like a century
saying like this is victorious
this is all sex sex xxx well it's but
it's more body image than sex i mean
it seems like they're going like it's
they wanna i think they're still going
to be sexy right
or is it just like great that lady is
not going to wear a [ __ ] song and
prance down
right well i don't think either of them
are but what i'm saying is are they what
are they going to wear are they going to
be going for sexy it's just sexy with an
athletic build they they're just saying
the rebranding
uh
the beleaguered lingerie giant is moving
away from its traditional rails and
models by introducing the versus
collective oh so the vs collective the
verses
i was like it's like versus one vs
collective um with diverse leading icons
and change makers
including
priyanka
jonas and megan rupino to shape the
future of the brand
okay so it's just a different collective
because that's right they're not gonna
get rid of them fully yeah i i
they're not why would they that's their
money yeah it's like mcdonald's having
salad where are you like ah
are you really about to we have it
we got to we they're here
we have apples remember they had apples
um i when i was in germany i did a i
went on an interview to work for an
advertising company
and one of the interview questions she's
like
i would think it's like ogilvy and
mathis anyway so she asks what do you
think of the dove campaign and i said
well i think it's pandering and i think
it's obvious
and i don't think it's effective and we
got in the biggest fight great it's like
this isn't going well
she's like trying outdoor well
um funny enough because i was so salty
about that like you asked me a question
right i was being honest i think all of
a sudden if you only have
white light-skinned like milk-pouring
commercials and then all of a sudden you
have like regular bodies i don't i just
felt pandering
their sales were down from that campaign
their sales well that's with all this
stuff is
i was watching something
where
like that show betty on hbo
oh wait betty or ugly betty the the
betty is a betty
dirty john betty
no there's a show called betty on hbo
and it's it's oh the skateboarder
skateboarder girls and they all seem
like
somewhat gender non-conforming
and i'm like do you like it i haven't
watched it no emotion wrote for it i
haven't watched it um but what i'm
saying is is that
as a
as a like is that for general audiences
meaning
right so but i think that that so is it
niche representative is is general
audience like right now i believe judd
was or is gonna do
a gay romantic comedy with billy
eichner right okay romantic comedy i
think fairly like standard romantic
comedy
but it's gay right i have that idea for
the gay action movie
uh actually [ __ ] hilarious uh
yeah i don't know i think i pitched
someone here right just no
pidgey i don't have the idea other than
like a guy has to save his husband
and he just has to do action at the end
they have a gay kiss
i would watch the [ __ ] yeah no it's it's
very funny
but so is that that's almost like
a little bit of a parody
yeah yeah you could make it like a
good it would be an action movie
just by the shot for shot and then at
the end they kiss it's a guy kissing guy
at what point does
you know like my best friend's wedding
rupert everett got a big punch from that
a big kick from that
i don't know what yeah like yeah he's
got like a
but it's still a straight woman married
a straight guy right
it's at what point do these things
does heterosexual it's it
can the gay stuff just be mainstream
i guess what i'm wondering is when will
straight guys because i think women are
open to it right
generally speaking yeah
but then i wonder when like and then i
wonder our 20 year old
uh boys now
do they still say like gay do they still
say
if someone said gay f-a-g-g-o-t like
each other like on a at a at a football
game right you know what i mean like i
don't is that i don't know any people
that age so i'm wondering if that's like
i do not think they say gay
someone said
oh what a [ __ ] and i was like well that's
like a secret one
but but like
that's
what a [ __ ] you gave him so you're like
great i love it no
but what i'm saying is is that a
generational thing where they don't
they just see bed i see a bunch of
knock it off girls that are probably
gender non-conforming or gay or whatever
i that's an assumption i make as an old
person
do young people see a show of just like
a bunch of girls i don't know like as
does a 20 year old boy see that and go
oh cool a new show right i like they
don't see race or any of that i don't
know
and i wonder if there's something i bet
there is something that we can't
prove but i think there's something as
you grow
old something in your brain that's
very open when you're young it just like
shrinks or just doesn't get as much i
don't know
but i'm not
no you're not as you get exposed to a
lot of [ __ ] though a lot of people
across all races and cultures get very
like ah
well yeah it's like get off my lawn
syndrome right or just like what i i
would never watch this type of
what if it's a good show like euphoria i
saw sam jay's show for like i saw the
first episode and then i was it
it
came up and it's sam
talking to
two
[Music]
stud
lesbians
who are they're just having a
conversation in the living room and the
two lesbians are topless
oh wow really in the yeah
and i'm like
is this norm like do do 20 year olds
watch this and just like oh
this is normal because as an old person
i'm like wow this is [ __ ] crazy yeah
but i'm also not that put off by it but
i wonder what a young person
i i wasn't even put off but i was like
this is
rare i've never seen this on tv right it
would have been a real sex segment 20
years ago yeah it would have been real
[ __ ] regular
tv show so i'm wondering if
that is mainstream now or if sam is
still outside of the mainstream yeah or
that maybe maybe like the angels are
i i feel like the victoria's secret and
that whole thing i feel like now it
feels dated
yeah but i don't know if i need now like
change makers in underwear like yeah i
don't know but there's also a lot of ass
videos on instagram i mean there's like
that's a problem and then bbl's are like
the number one procedure everybody gets
yeah so is that like but
everyone's vegan in la but also that we
have the
artisan pizza [ __ ] like it's just
there's always like and then like these
like burger spots have a line down and
the hot chicken but we're vegan but we
recycle but like so i don't know i think
everyone's kind of
less aware of they're full of shitness i
get it if it's sex if it's like a
corporation going like we like you're
not going to get those carls junior drip
and barbecue sauce come on
like that's and and victoria's secret is
near is in that area and it feels dated
like that it feels like frederik see yes
it feels like playboy yeah centerfold
or like um what was that while on e
remember how she would go to these
parties
just it just feels kind of dated so i
get it but
go on instagram and see how dated sexism
and butts are and tits and they're
in vogue yeah so i don't know what's
happening
as usual i'm pretty perceptive and have
no [ __ ] idea what's happening
anyhow
[Music]
you've got mail
hey neil and bianca lst er uh my husband
who's also feeler and i just went to
charleston south carolina and our
honeymoon while we were there we visited
a plantation that had a
tour called from slavery to freedom
which we thought seemed like an
acceptable way to visit a plantation
because it acknowledged the
enslaved people who lived there however
part of the tour included talking about
the tour guide who was a middle-aged
white guy uh made a point of mentioning
that slaves were sold to white settlers
or explorers by powerful african kings
who took over weaker tribes and that
brazil and the caribbean were much
bigger importers of african slaves than
the us we both felt that even if this
was in correct information it was in
poor taste because they should have just
been focusing on
the
history of that particular plantation
and the fact that people were kept there
as chattel can you pause her real quick
i've never had a better sense of
someone's eyeballs than this woman
i like could draw i like no i feel like
i know every part of her eyeball so
weird i can't explain it
uh how ally mcneil feel and what banker
bell thinker both
hi oh my god ally mcneil oh i didn't
catch it um now i caught it thank you
uh
you're welcome
the
no i you don't just don't white
wrestling even just
i don't know man it's i
would you go to uh auschwitz
no but i've been to like um journey i
went to right i guess i went to the
museum
this feels like a fun tour
like it's fun and what it's like feels
like yay it's old
yeah it's like it's like the old west or
something yeah it's literally
sit around while massa is hiding in the
woods and the white refugees which i
went to by the way and it was as good as
advertising sold out
uh yeah um
yeah that's not good and also
i also think they get if you work on a
plantation you're getting a lot of
they they probably just want to make it
not as bad like you know
actually they there were kings that
you know they were there there were
worse slave owners
fyi and we didn't even want the slaves
we were sailing past africa
and the tribal kings met
got our attention from the shore
and say look i just captured these
slaves i'm trying to get rid of them
they seem you guys have giant yards
that need work
do you need help
because i got extras we have extras
extra blacks here
so if you would
we don't even want them if you could
take them off our hands
it would make a huge difference to us
so we in and just tell people in the
future that we forced you to do it we're
the evil ones you guys are doing us a
favor i i feel like you worked for
plantation i would like to
um that's where his show is you guys yes
um so
yeah it's not i mean thanks for turning
yourself in
but i don't
um i don't don't do that don't go to a
slave also i
you know i believe plantations are
haunted
and it's not i just think you know i
don't know we should
like when people get married at
plantations like
you really want a bunch of
all right
you want slave ghosts
did i ever tell you there's a story okay
this lady
they were doing some construction in the
yard
and she digs up bones
and they look and they try to figure it
out and based on the area it was it was
it's like unmarked grave slave bones so
this is a white lady she re-buries them
now house honda
poltergeist
up the wazoo
she can't get rid of them like the
poultry guys
and
uh
then everyone in her family starts dying
in the house
she comes down with can and everyone in
the neighborhood starts coming down with
cancer and then they they were like do
we have slave bones in ours people
started digging up their slave bones
slaves revenge
and they just start killing like this
the ghosts are tails in the hood it's
literally tails from
tell me tell us these people had a
wonderful talent it was it was a story
that got cut but just okay yeah
slave bones be careful be careful with
them guys
uh give them away
as presents
just see their dinos they're they
dinos whatever dinosaurs or something
okay and then see and then if they get
haunted be like i don't know i gave you
dinosaur bones okay if there's a
dinosaur hunting you then don't uh
haunting you then don't [ __ ] look at
me goodbye you've got mail what's up
neil and bianca it's eva shaw the
musical
that's all those beats for you guys so
vicky we think and all that stuff those
were great thanks for playing everything
i wanted to make a comment about you
guys talking about
neil
becoming a woman for
a short amount of time to try to
understand why
we get upset when we get attention
and sort of like unintentionally asking
for attention i think bianca's main
point is that even if we don't try to
ask for attention with our outfits we
still get it
so of course if you're gonna go and
dress sexy and go to a club that's one
side of it but the other side is the
everyday kind of [ __ ] that we have to
deal with i mean i don't really like
wearing bras and i have nice boobs so if
it's cold and i'm in whole foods and i'm
just trying to buy some brussels sprouts
i don't really want a weird creepo like
staring at my tits i don't think that it
should be our responsibility to try to
figure out how we can cover ourselves up
so that men don't make us uncomfortable
men you have to take a little bit more
responsibility
and just kind of know when's the right
time and place and kind of how to act
you can also just appreciate a woman's
beauty without making some creepy
comment so yeah that's all i wanted to
say and i love you guys i listen all the
time so please don't take a break
um peace
eva
also god what a lovely voice
i liked her
she is a i like her attitude she has a
bad attitude and i thought i like it
um she's trying to get some brussels
sprouts yeah also she sounds healthy
brussels sprouts
you know
perky
boobs i like boobs uh yeah i don't
uh
you're not
gonna
probably
uh
get men to know when to
be creepy or not
it's just too big and ask it's the the
the factory settings of man are not to
be considerate to women but this is this
is the west
really does
uh allow men to be creepy and the onus
is on women whereas i feel like
and i'm not gonna go defend the middle
east in their treatment of women but i
know when i've been there
men aren't allowed to just like wear
whatever they want and women have to be
in cloaks you know like guys can't wear
shorts right in iraq
great no flip-flops yeah no flip-flops
no shirts joking but like guys can't
really wear
they can't show that much skin either
right so in my head and you can't go
harass a woman because you can they're
gonna take this video down in iran
because of how much skin i'm showing
right now
uh not good i'm yeah so i just i wonder
i think culturally
is there i feel like it's just it's
always on women to because of course and
what she's saying is like there's
examples of when you just want to like
look good feel good i'm wearing a cute
outfit then there's examples of i'm just
trying to get
like i just need to get to cvs in she's
at whole foods what's she wearing
in your mind she's wearing a jacket with
a t-shirt
it might be a light colored t-shirt we
can we see a little nip here and there
as she's moving as she's looking at
brussels sprouts rock hard go ahead she
she is not giving off a inviting energy
i don't think oh well yeah well that's
the thing that guys could
she's not like discern
yes
it's
the thing you gotta remember
is
people complain about men and women
and it's a a lot of times it's they're
all hand in hand meaning
guys don't like
that women
uh get hormonal sometimes you're like
[ __ ]
we acting like a [ __ ] and all that
stuff during her period and then yet
they like they love her fat ass now the
reason she has fat ass is because she's
got wide hips
and there's got wide hips because she's
got ovaries and the reason she's got
ovaries is because she has to
uh
have a period to make a baby at some
point etc so it's all connected allie
mcneil allen was really fine
so
and then women don't like the guys are
so
irrationally confident and aggressive
and then every once in a while
you like it when we're aggressive and
the reason we're aggressive is because
we can or or you want us to protect you
you want us to and it's like it's all
the same thing it's all like i ha when i
hear a noise in the middle of the night
i have to go yeah [ __ ] i'll take him
i don't even know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about but it's and that's the
same thing that makes guys go i'll go
investigate the noise
if it's an animal white guys
what do black guys do
i feel like in movies they make black
people like what's that noise and then
they get killed but i'm like the old
joke is that white people are like you
know it's eddie murphy going like get
out of the house like
um
so
it's the same thing like that made us
kill animals
but it makes us go like oh sh it's just
the same for sure there's primal
physiological things going on but you
live near irwin whole foods
someone's going to do a reverse vector
search
and get nano moles and figure out where
i live
i'm as good as dad i'm sorry
i just mean
we are yes but we live in a really it's
about me and you yeah but i don't know
we live in a nice place in a nice part
of the world my body doesn't know what
year it is
it's 10 000 bc
honestly your body didn't [ __ ] know
what year it is it's like
your body is understand that but what is
what do you have a responsibility not to
creep a girl out at [ __ ]
yes but i
am i don't want to be a creep like that
like i specifically used
to but why not just like hey guys don't
say anything
okay hey guys don't say anything i mean
not like you say it right i'm just
saying why not why isn't that a
why isn't that part of our culture like
it's very much on women if you want to
get into it it's probably a moral issue
and it's
a it's like entertainment it's at it's
worse it's an abuse of power it's like
um
like i'm gonna look now
like
upskirts the fact that there are
upskirts
shots is so crazy to me as like a thing
yeah
um
but that's just people are looking for
advantages and [ __ ]
people are gross and immoral
it's no good isn't no good but boy oh
boy now that we know eva shaw
has nice boobs and she eats whole foods
brussels we just got a little we got a
step
you don't have to take this
stay
and there's also fellas wanting to do
with like a you know three second roll
of like something drops on the floor
eat it before three seconds you're gonna
look at a woman don't linger more than
three seconds be quick about it right
because women do it quickly you can't
tell i will i could never look directly
at a guy just in my peripheral and be
like he's he's the hottest guy in the
world yeah i just it's easy yep thank
you it's a developed skill goodbye
you've got mail hey neil and binks it is
the criminal justice data guy from last
week and first i have to apologize for
trying to morning zoo it
it did not go well and hand up that's on
me i think my ultimate point was just be
weary of any study that reaches a
conclusion about the entire criminal
justice system in the united states
one
there are 51 different justice systems
with the federal system in each of the
50 states and it's just very hard to
extrapolate out and reach conclusions
based on that just because data
collection varies from state to state
and even within state from county to
county so it's just very hard to reach
conclusions when you talk about
something like total charges that
doesn't make a distinction between
misdemeanor and felonies or doesn't make
a distinction whether it's the initial
charge or eventual charge of conviction
and doesn't take into account possible
plea agreements i just think it's
difficult to say
definitively across the united states
that
this is happening that all charges are
less than a gram
don't get me wrong the entire system is
[ __ ] up no matter which way you
measure it
i don't know why i decided to call in
last week clearly it was an impulse
decision that did not really land well
or go over well
the ultimate point was and i know neil
loves a good study just would appreciate
a little bit more skepticism
with any study that attempts to
reach a conclusion for the entire us
criminal justice system
uh yeah he still hasn't sold us and he
came off his original point yes this guy
gets worse every week and there's like
us there's a giant
there's a 12-year vet who wrote in
annihilating this yes
so we'll get to the wait your turn son
you're you'll have a seat we're gonna
annihilate you any moment now swing in a
miss
uh that's all the video yeah audio great
i know we've got it good bye
i'm a gen z tweener born in 98.
listening to this week's sistah podcast
neil you mentioned you don't like
musicals i was curious about your
perspective on bo burnham's new special
inside
in my generation it's been hailed his
magnum opus i loved it
i loved it myself personally i know he
directed chris and drudd's most recent
specials so i feel like he's a part of
the comedy cool club and i also feel
like you guys would make him sit with
weird al yankovic
um
if is is he taken seriously amongst the
elder statesman of comedy what neily
ophelia what pink gianco thonko
uh wait weirdo
well he's saying like he'd be like he
thinks weird owls relegated to
hacky territory which what do comics do
comics like buddha
yeah but it's
all comics like a more than
regular comics all comics like them
because they all grew up on them right
but
a lot of it has to do with
style
in terms of musical comedy that we don't
think that
music like lonely island's [ __ ]
hilarious right um
dalia made in a rap album that i thought
was [ __ ] hilarious
yeah uh chat oh yes it was actually this
is [ __ ] funny yeah and it had it was
funny he said he was from prim nevada
which always made me laugh because it's
such a dumb [ __ ] place to be
shank smith was the name
um and um
and lonely island's [ __ ] hilarious
you know
piss on you it's funny like they're it's
not like it's impossible to do funny
song it's just the style around it
that is
hacky
and that's where people go like oh
you're just a bad guy
it was [ __ ] excellent so
it's not there's no bias against
musical comedy i don't i like musical
uh i like i kind of liked the um
book of mormon i i it's too long to me
these things are just too long like but
if you made
an album of
funny songs i'd listen to it maybe right
it's not like i have a bunch of lonely
island songs on my phone like that you
listen to mm-hmm
there are songs there are lonely island
songs that are so [ __ ] funny to me
that and they're very good musical
musically because they got
real producers to produce them yeah
that's the trick like rock got prince
paul to do no no sex in the champagne
room
me and dave
yeah is good who did you guys get we got
this guy's stephen gold who
is partners with this guy uh
who died of covet actually from fountain
and he's a good musician and did a good
r kelly parody track so and then we used
a mirror after that like so
we did a tupac one with the mirror and
james poison so
it's not it's just a matter of like are
they good jokes sandler is a
something of a guitar act yeah but he's
[ __ ] really funny yeah so like that
song
like jewish kids loved that hanukkah oh
that was like played a lot yeah lunch
ladyland like there's a sandler's got
bangers so
it's not heaps not relegated at all he's
considered bose how did you did you like
bose st did you watch it right it's
great yeah and it's
is it music yeah it's music and then
a couple like non-music things
and it's just about being stuck and like
sort of a
nervous breakdown
arc
um
but
it's and the songs are [ __ ] funny so
um i had a the i wrote down uh ron white
because i rogan talked about it this
week i mentioned it off the air
a few weeks ago and because i haven't
talked about ayahuasca in an hour so i
need to bring it up
um legally i'm about to lose i'm going
to lose we're going to lose our
broadcasting license if i don't bring it
up
uh as i've heard rogan mentioned it
apparently ron white ron white who's
known as a
soggy drunk has a tequila company
a few months ago did ayahuasca
and ron white quit drinking
i repeat
ron white
quit drinking
i almost don't believe it i know
um
yeah he quit drinking that's an old one
uh rogan talked about it so it's you're
not gonna be able to find it but
but uh i'd heard about it from theo and
then
it's [ __ ] insane yeah so plant plants
plant medicine hey neil binky and will
long time second time recently i was
reflecting on what the first podcast i
ever listened to was and remembered it
was the champs back in 2011. while
champs obviously had some major stars on
it it's no surprise but still so amazing
to see some of the guests you and moshe
introduced to us that were relatively
early in their fame turned out to be
some of the biggest stars in household
names today michael shea tiffany haddish
trevor noah to name a few uh for those
who haven't who want to go back and
listen gerard was the first guest my
question is who are some comedians
writers you and banks think
uh are incredibly talented and predict
will be a big star in the next five to
ten years
i read this before the show and i was
like i don't i'm not
you know what's interesting is
people don't
it's like an old man complaint people
don't have to develop as long anymore
um
in that
you're just like good oh you know who's
good and i always forget his name
uh brian simpson brian simpson's really
good very good um who's really good he's
black dude sort of
thick
and like squat it's like a squat blocker
it's it's like i think he worked the
door at the store right yeah he worked
for a second yeah um
i feel like jack's
dad jax jack knight has um
like he is i mean jack's like he's like
i'm already famous energy yeah he's had
famous energy since he was a kid but
he's just got like
pogoey
cute
energy yeah he's got the work and he's
attractive he's great logan and he's
tall he's got like
palpable add mm-hmm like but he has fun
palpable
yes my worry for jack is
that he never
like figures out how to do an hour
that is like
organized in a through line and
remembers what jokes to do
i feel like
like what and then he's just off into
some other [ __ ] doesn't that isn't that
kind of what
you try to develop as a comic isn't that
something it's not like comics can just
off the bat have an hour no but they you
have jokes that you've written that are
like structured so you need to like
actually work on that
i i don't i haven't watched enough of
jack to i know whenever i watch him
i feel like
it's part of his gift is like he's never
done the joke before
and he may forget it that's what i when
i watched that guy so good you're like
he may not remember that joke i i i
don't that could just be his appeal and
it could be a choice but that's when i
watch jack i'm like
he
it's like an and one mixtape guy where
it's like [ __ ] drip sticking the ball
on your inside dog
can you play in an organized office i'm
i'm sure again he's been writing for a
lot of shows yeah he's very good so it's
funny being friends with comedians the
best the funniest thing is when they say
something funny
i don't know why it's this weird power
you have over you just go like write
that down and they do it yeah like
okay you never yeah
you know what i'm gonna write this i'm
gonna write this out i don't know if i
can write but
um you know who's ron taylor is very
funny i don't know what he's funny ron
is ron has energy that
you can't
work on you can't purchase you can't ron
is a genuine he is weirdo [ __ ] up
he opened for me twice during cobit and
he was
almost missed a spot twice oh my god
okay yeah no he ron is he's yeah but
he's
he has a
special thing
he's like a peculiar old man in a 30
year old's body he's like you can't
you cannot he's very fun he's funnier
than like i'm like ron go
do
taylor brian simpson
oh i mean my my one of my closest
friends is punky yeah but
she's already doing it but for a very
long time she just was like
i'm just gonna i'm gonna serve i'm gonna
be a bartender
i'm gonna put in my time
and now she's on snl yep yeah so
and stars are just like us
you can
she dreamed she dreamed a dream
i love it we're only promoting the
blacks
happy birthday
june 20th
um and faheem's very funny
i feel like i mean i don't know yeah
people they know him more
is so funny yeah for him and what's his
um
alternative lance lance cansapolis god
um
fahim's writing first show on cbs
he wrote during covet and now he's going
to go back and i'm like all right don't
get don't fall into the money trap i
know that's because those running jobs
are good money and then you go do i even
want to perform and then and then next
thing you know you're wearing a plaid
shirt yeah and khakis at khakis and
you're giving you've got a script and
you're getting coffee you're at soup
plantation you're at starbucks
i mean he's just got a good
theme's just fun and for him used to
open for me and i would say fame's great
because he's got great jokes and no
confidence
they're just the kind of guy you want in
front of you because the audience you
train the audience to like good thoughts
but they don't
they still like you more than him
perfect opener goodbye you've got mail
um hey neil and bianca i'm a day one fan
who was writing in for some advice i
work at pretty well established
foundation that collects and puts out
polls and collects data for research
purposes to help promote liberal policy
in different political institutions
when i took the job i was a liberal
woman filled with hope and a sense of
purpose i'm rock hard now i feel like a
liar and i've developed pretty deep
depression when i entered this
profession i was unaware of the level of
underhanded tactics that make the
numbers say
what you want them to say some of the
ways it's done is by selecting for a
group that has an overall
that overall leans toward a specific
opinion phrasing the question in a poll
a certain way or simply cherry picking
stats one example
uh is a recent study that shows white
people overrepresented in crimes against
asians the study was already somewhat
controversial because when the numbers
showed another group overrepresented
they lowered the criteria to include
verbal harassment
as violence another is a conservative
study that came out recently showing
that only african-americans and
college-educated white women supported
critical race theory in school but only
20 percent of people knew what critical
race theory was
uh these studies from ideological
institutions are used in articles cited
by professors and politicians who all
know the way the data is manipulated i'm
told the other side does it so we need
to combat them but i feel like this is
the real reason donald trump was
successful in demonizing the media and
it also makes me feel like a
propagandist more than a data analyst
any advice would be extremely helpful
it's like the underbelly
what do you i mean it's a this is a dave
story but
dave dabs another
day
dave that was one of the first
uh
black students at brown university i
think maybe the in the first class
so he's a big
big brain [ __ ] right
wasn't it was it was a data analyst and
statistician and
was watching this happen it was like i
can't do this [ __ ] um
and he went to africa i'm kidding
um uh and so he quit and became a
professor
um
so yeah it happens and i don't know what
the answer i mean that's there are times
where when i'm reading
almost anything i'm like yeah maybe
maybe this is true
yeah i did because most things there's a
i just downloaded a book called um
uh
i don't remember what it's called but
it's about
um
how they just go with
these [ __ ]
studies and then there's an article and
and they can't it's uh they can't
replicate most of them well yeah also
this is nothing new like i know she's
like oh a liberal woman but this is ev
take anything
and apply i mean like i remember
i
my i
never mind i'll tell that story another
time anyways i got an argument with this
friend of mine who is vegan
and
uh everything you're saying was [ __ ]
she's like actually no
the reason why i believe this is because
the china study i was like okay [ __ ] i
like researching so i went i researched
it this is a study she's like there's a
village in china that there's no access
to anything so they are like they're
forced to live a vegan lifestyle there's
no
you know rate of cancer there's no rate
of this there's no rate of that it's all
so low and it's a proof then some guy
took it and was like yo there's this
study that
that is not it that's actually not it
what happened was there was a study over
30 years
and there was they found cancer in every
village they just kind like there's
there's so much death this china studies
massive it's massive there's like i
don't know what she cherry picked but
yeah it was like a document or something
[ __ ] right so then this guy came no
there's a guy that came in like the 90s
or whatever and
apparently he's a failed uh
like musician they're all failed actors
very musicians failed no i feel like
he's like he wanted to be this kind of
profound dude in statistics and didn't
and couldn't get there so he took this
study
and statistical
[Laughter]
you're nothing but a statistical
statistic go ahead
and he just manipulated it to be like
yeah
vegan and i'm not saying you know
there's plenty of proof out there
towards veganism but he just manipulated
the china study to say that like nope
this proves that there's no rate of
these type of cancers when you eat a
vegan and it's just like dog you just
yeah i mean there's it
you can manipulate any statistic for
what you want we can literally find we
can just take an opinion and we will
find articles with statistics and a
study behind it
for each of our pin
all right that's i think that's what the
podcast is
i'm not mistaken yeah it's it's uh i
don't
i'm surprised you know she didn't know
that going in who this lady that's what
i'm saying it's not like a new yeah it
kind of seems like that's what it is
goodbye right you've got married this is
the long letter okay go hit it i'm 13
year old veteran police officer with a
college education and supervisor
experience i've also trained officers in
the academy and on the street and i'm a
damn good cop
i'm a damn good cop
you tell the mayor
i'm a damn good cop i'm ready to tell
you that in my uh experience police are
not racist
in the state i live in the police are
very diverse and are trained at the
academy to put away
any differences and work together
uh different races are look are made to
bunk together sit in the classroom mixed
together
and so on uh look at it this way if you
are ever in trouble and you have to
scream on the radio that your life's in
danger and you need help you don't care
what color the officer is that comes to
back you up and save your life although
if he's white kind of means a little
more you know what i mean so the first
thing so the first time you were ever in
trouble and uh an officer of another
race helps you out of a jam you aren't
racist anymore same as the military
veterans
uh
right there i'm like
i don't know man i don't know
i don't think that racists are racist
because a black person never did
anything nice for him right
anyway although of course there are
going to be some bad police officers and
racist officers because police officers
are human beings but if you have to look
at it this way the police off the police
force in any area is a sample group of
that area
yes and no because a lot of times they
live in [ __ ] valley valley if you are
taking police recruits from a pool of
people such as a large city it will have
proportionately the same amount of
diversity and bad people slash police as
that place go to a bad place they have
bad officers i know dude but they can't
that can't be you have to wheat
ideally you would weed them out the
compton like yeah let's go to compton
right they have bad officers that have
been protected for at least 50 years so
what
right it's also like we they have to be
better than the general population right
uh percentage-wise the officers will
commit crimes at the same percentage
rate as the community in which they are
pulled from
memphis has high crime their police
recruits are hired from that area a
large uh portion of those police
recruits will commit a crime
break policy and be terrible officers i
almost want to stop reading this
police are just people and six months of
training can't fix or weed out
everyone needed i could fix the issue
but i need to write a book
pay a wage worth
worth risking your life an infinite
budget for training and so on
okay
uh the problem in this country is that
the entire criminal justice system is
broken it's not racist but rather a
classic system uh you could argue that
racism has led to this system but for a
moment let's say that the system is now
not racist but classes
when i was a rookie officer i brought up
the issue of racism in courtrooms how
black offenders seem to be
disproportionately prosecuted and
convicted my chief told me that one day
i would learn that the only color that
mattered in the courtroom was green
uh for money uh
do you have money to afford expensive
attorneys expense expert witnesses month
agreed yep that's racially uh
this is too long there's just the just
read the last paragraph this is your
favorite part lastly bianca is
completely correct about most rugger x i
should have just skipped to this i know
i was like lastly bianca is completely
correct about most drug arrests being
small amounts of drugs and minor
misdemeanors every police agency in the
united states that is nationally
accredited submits a yearly quarterly
crime
statistics analysis
to the
fbi it can meet the crime felony or
misdemeanor drug offense and race of the
person in charge where does that guy
that called in uh called in think the
aclu and other places get their stats
from bianca is again correct most people
aren't walking around with kilos
most street cops are
encountering small drug offenses for
personal use prohibition does not work
drug addiction should be a family church
addiction problem and not a police
problem plant sing the plane medicine
song
then he wrote plant medicine assuming
that we play the song
um we'll of course we'll not do that
um i'd like to remain anonymous i don't
think will's paying attention he doesn't
know him he was doing praying like
i'd like to remain anonymous but
anonymous
that's not trump
that's how trump pronounces it and i i
started saying it as a joke with devin
the writer for the daily show and now i
say anonymous
but if bianca would like to discuss any
of this over drinks she can email me oh
i can email you i don't like it it's a
tough one that's a tough one you need a
burner girl
um
yeah again
the last paragraph okay now he said i
was correct twice so i literally was
doing this via satellite
a little delayed
um
but that's what i know of they everyone
reports that
i don't i still don't know what the
first guy's talking about
he's like how would know i'm like it's
like what what do you think
it's plea deals they're pleading to a
certain amount they're not going to
plead to they might play to last but not
that much less in the justice system
actually this
like the paperwork is actually
correct like the charges they keep track
of all that i mean we've got to give it
that
in the justice system of all the [ __ ]
that's going on i because he's right a
lot of people use the same statistics so
i'm like
i know we've just
good for you buddy and i hope that you
and bianca have one hell of a date and i
hope that the memphis police
there's a lot of nonsense in the letter
but some good stuff let's do the last
one because it's shorter the very last
one goodbye you've got mail hey neil and
bianca i was listening i love listening
to you guys each week neil i like your i
don't care about most [ __ ] attitude
bianca i love your confidence
intelligence and your multilingual
talents hello i was however
a bit disappointed to hear the comment
on the last show where you both said
dominicans are black
i would go so far as to saying that the
majority of dominicans have some afro
latino features
but i do not
like this generalization
as a proud dominican i've been asked if
i'm greek italian brazilian and or
several other types of latin american or
even which parent is dominican
i don't like these questions and i think
it all stems from the generalization
that dominicans all look the same which
of course isn't the case i think i would
i think it would have been more accurate
to say most dominicans
as i said i love the pod and had a great
feeling each time you guys have
mentioned dominicans
uh but also just wanted to throw that
out there since i love being dominican
and feel like this recent comment
actively excludes me slash my family i
would go on
but i don't want to
get the the crazy [ __ ] sending long
emails dude the last sentence is so
funny
and had a great feeling each time you
guys would mention dominicans
i would argue well first of all this
lady's playing the game of it's not all
yes but in comedy lady if it's most it's
all right we got it
that's the rule so over 70
if i say women x and it's
not over 70 it's not gonna get a laugh
right it just will not work but also
like this now we love you for listening
but this does prove a point of
our point was that dominicans do not
want to be called black
yet this was the first place
where black people were imported yes as
slaves yes christopher columbus espanola
i'm like but then you're not black no no
no so we i'm also black i'm a southern
black woman i'm afro-latin sure but i'm
still a black woman right so you could
be like naomi campbell's
uh like
like chinese jamaican
she's still not yeah yeah like her
grandma's actually chinese there's a lot
of like chinese in jamaica but she's
still a black woman like right you're
black
i don't
listen the caribbean has weird identity
around being cold black like puerto
ricans
do not say they're black even though i'm
like
i would argue i mean if you're going
it's just it's the whole thing everybody
can have more
african afro
african features than
puerto ricans
right in my experience so i'm just
saying when like okay let's just go back
in time like everyone it's pretty easy
to trace it's not like
what
mesozoic
so
i don't know this
i feel like
so this person just doesn't have afro
latin features
understanding she does she does
just not that many
how many
micro parent is more
nano morals do you have
uh
yeah
yeah i don't dominicans or the blackest
looking
latin people
in my experience yeah and noodles lived
in norway i'm about to be in new york
and the joke i used to do with davidoff
is in new york everyone's a little
puerto rican it's true yeah everyone's a
little porter it's just the weather
makes everyone a little puerto rican
even the whitest upper west side like
lauren michaels is a little puerto rican
michael's is not puerto rican he's a
little puerto rican
um
everyone's carrying around a boom box a
little bit even if they're not and i'm
not talking
blou punk speakers with the bluetooth
attachment i'm talking about 1980s
what we used to call a ghetto blast
again i was gonna say he's gonna get um
are you
when the
winter's coming
when winter comes are you just gonna be
there i might be which i don't which i
which we're not happy about then you're
not going to be puerto rican i know then
i'm the whitest of white runny nose and
[ __ ]
i got but you guys know i got bad
circulation we're we're done with this
[ __ ] right very good
[Music]
brussels sprout aisle loud and clear
i'll be looking
sticking my head out of the brussels
sprouts
goodbye